in the first video of this trip I
babbled on about the whole Sweden
massive entertainment experience only
touching based on a few of the changes
in my thoughts around parts the game
that I was able to test in this video
I'm going to go through the dark zone
and PvP elements that are being
introduced into the division to
[Music]
in the presentation beforehand they
address something that they felt had
been holding back the community toxicity
and when we talk about toxicity and the
division we're talking about one
particular area the dark zone when the
dark zone was first announced long
before the release of the first game
this concept was feeling new to games a
lawless area where players who lived
pretty much do whatever they wanted it
was sort of a social experiment on the
plus side anyone who chose to venture
into this area was rewarded with the
best high-end loot drop rates in the
game this concept alone brought a large
number of players unfamiliar with the
genre to the division however over time
players wanting to access this higher
loop drop potential complained about the
unfair nature of this area it should be
noted that my first couple of years in
the game were mostly played solo and 90%
of the star was in the dark zone taking
advantage of this high-risk high-reward
area
I understood the risks associated with
the area and that 30 minutes of looting
could be lost if I was caught off guard
by a group of four or even another solo
agent roaming the area but it was still
the fastest place to loot gear and it
had the certain appeal in a predictable
nature but I still struggled to
replicate in other games personally I
found this area to really test my skills
in game whether it to see how stealthy I
could be with my farming or to see how
far I could go is a solo player taking
on groups of ropes yes I had my fair
share of heckie heckie comments but I
take these as a bit of an unofficial
in-game achievement over the years I've
watched the duck zone go from an
exciting and scarily fun area to
somewhere not worth entering unless
you're looking for some PvP and even
that wasn't guaranteed so now that you
know where I stand on this whole subject
please don't take my opinion as gospel
this is simply my view as a day one
mostly solo player okay so now that
we've covered that what's happening with
the dark zone in the division - firstly
we'll start with some of the changes
that were implemented in order to
address the concerns around toxicity in
the game fredley fire this was removed
from the division of one of the more
recent updates I have mixed feelings on
this although it removed a lot of the
annoying chicken dancing between groups
of non rogues and they're diving into
the firing line of players shooting at
NPCs in order to have them going
accidental rogue it did remove some of
the unpredictability of the dark zone as
you are now warned well in advance of
the intentions of other players
however for the majority of the
community the pros far outweigh the cons
so in the division to have continued
this void while creeping through the
dark zone holding on to my precious loot
looking for the right opportunity to
trigger off an extraction more often
than not hearing the voices of the
approaching teams was my first
indication that I needed to stay hidden
or move on of course at the same time
this was also the easiest way to hurl
abuse at ena when you came across the
division sort of became infamous is a
place for players to really let out
their inner toxic selves in the early
days I match made with groups who
admitted that this is one of the best
things implemented into the game the
ability to downright verbally destroy
anyone they came across while I
certainly wasn't an advocate of this
there's always the option in the menu of
turning this off but sometimes I'd love
to hear what people thought of me
especially after benching a team of four
on my own and believe me I play an
Australian service I thought I'd heard
it all but these kids and grown-ass
adults taught me a few new words and
phrases in the division to avoid has
been turned off there is no way to talk
to other people in dark so unless you
group up with them and add them to your
party while this would certainly remove
a lot of the toxic speech the option has
always been there except now we don't
have a choice not only do I feel this
will take away from the hostile feel of
the dark zone but also I can think of a
number of examples of people who have
actually made in-game frames with people
through the use of point agents blessed
with the gift of the gab sorry you can
no longer talk your way out of these
situations yes it was used as a way to
be particularly toxic but it added
another layer to the dark zone that
couldn't be experienced anywhere else in
the game other changes include gain
normalization the dark zone and the
division to will have gear normalization
I'm not a huge fan of us it's something
that's been used in other areas of PvP
like Last Stand and it means the players
who may not have spent a thousand hours
in PvE grinding the best gear are able
to still stay competitive but when it
came to the dark zone your hard earned
gear pays off not anymore in a way to
level the playing field as such player
gear is now normalized in the dark zone
in the division one that meant the gear
was rounded down to non classified
levels in the division two we haven't
heard too much about gear sets so it's
hard to say what this will affect at the
stage multiple dark zones in the first
game there is one dark zone that almost
splits the map and two
in the division - we have multiple dark
zones located on the outside of the map
DZ west east and south these dark zones
each look and play very differently
DZ East is quite overgrown with
vegetation and can almost appear a
little Missy but when it gets dark in
this area it really gets dark there is a
lot more place to hide and I found it
much easier to be ambushed in this map
DZ south was much more open it felt a
little cleaner well as far as a
post-apocalyptic city could feel anyway
there were clearer sight lines and ahead
a slightly familiar field - the dark
zone in the original game we weren't
able to play DZ West but the general
idea behind this was that it was based
around the wealthier side of the city
residential area where there are smaller
buildings and more choke points the
darker Zone I didn't catch the name of
this so for now I'm just calling it the
darker zone or hardcore DZ this is a
version of the dark zone with some of
the changes above don't apply and start
to make a little more sense time and
time again you've seen the suggestion of
a PvE dark zone this didn't really make
sense I mean we already have one of
those the light zone or pretty much any
other area of the map that was in the
dark zone so instead what they're
offering here is two types of dark zone
the standard dark zone with slightly
reduced duck so ninis and the new
hardcore dark zone this won't have a
static location on the map instead it
will move around the existing dark zone
locations we're unsure as to how often
this will be at the stage but for
example let's say that it's in the DZ
east one week and next week it could be
in DZ cells in the hardcore dark zone
there will be friendly fire and there
will be no normalization of gear this
dark zone will be the one that we
remember from the earlier days of the
division on top of us it'll be the
location where the best gear can be
found with the highest loot drops so
again a high-risk high-reward area I
fill this new dark zone concept with a
new more challenging iteration that
moves around the map will help with
offering a softer side to the DZ for the
more casual player but then again if the
darker zone truly offers a more
lucrative experience I can see the
community once again being split in two
with the players not wanting to engage
in PvP or run the risk of being ganked
screaming out for a more friendly
alternative personally I hope massive
will stand the ground on this one but
time will tell
one thing that won't be implemented into
the darker zone is void this will
continue to be disabled the gameplay in
the dark zone felt relatively similar
but there seemed to be a little more
interaction with the story of the game
in the first instance we found ourselves
alone with the DZ to ourselves so we
tested out a few of the new additions to
the mode firstly there's an additional
rogue mode previously we had rogue red
and manhunt yellow now we have a third
tier great which is more like petty
theft or self flagging rogue wannabe
rogue if you like during this there are
many rogue objectives and a number of
side rooms you can unlock we were having
a few issues coordinating our team due
to the language barriers so we could
only look into a couple of these but it
turns out these weren't activated for
this event anyway from what we could see
it looks like an alternative way for
gathering Luke for Oaks one thing that
did take our group by surprise is the
new turrets that defend the check points
while rogue we ran back to the
checkpoint in an attempt to change
service we wanted to find some actual
players but before we made it there half
our team got chained down by turrets
this has obviously been implemented to
stop the checkpoint camping that it's
been much complained about in the
division 1 this can easily be avoided by
standing back from the checkpoints
however I do see this as a point of
future complaints I'm not sure if this
was because of our level but they did
seem to deal a hell of a lot of damage
and quickly it probably wouldn't hurt if
they weren't quite so effective maybe
similar to the turrets in the Falcons
lost incursion eventually after the team
managed to run off rogue or just died
two turrets we change service
immediately we can some rogues
but then again due to the communication
issues we were split in two while I was
frantically trying to keep up with Marco
we came across a group of four rogues
trying to extract as we had the jump on
them even with just the two of us on
controllers we were able to quickly drop
the entire squad before they knew what
was going on I was a little too excited
to really embrace the new cover shooter
mechanics but because they had no idea
of what was going on at didn't matter
the next group found us for v2 without
the element of surprise we will quickly
take him down this played out a few more
times and although I'd say staying
behind cover isn't the only way it
certainly gave out a bit of an advantage
no matter what we tried cover was a much
better way to take on a face-to-face
battle
next we were down to try out some
conflict domination as you'd expect this
new PvP mode puts two teams of four
against each other the objective is to
capture the zones and hold them to gain
points I'll be the first to admit I
spent a lot of this time trying out new
weapons and exploring the random site
objectives around the map one of which
seem to give a mode which is
specialization my usual tactics of
running out and holding my own wasn't
working it felt like there was a lot
more teamwork involved again it was hard
to break the habit of the usual chicken
dance style of PvP but a couple of
players utilizing cover mechanics
properly would quickly shut you down
unless you hit the bus pros I won't go
into the details of the healing and
weapons of the stage as I'll be covering
them in more depth in the next video but
the majority of what I know about PvP
has changed and as much as I like PvP in
the division I completely agree that was
a bit weird and I welcome this change we
will meet to try out some conflicts
skirmish two but due to running out of
time we must up summing up there are a
number of changes coming to the dark
zone focusing on reducing the toxicity
and the player skill gap with the
intention of having more people getting
involved but with the introduction of
the darker zone we may be seeing the DZ
that we had in the beginning of division
1 making your turn PvP still has a
similar feel to what we currently have
but with more emphasis on the cover
shooter mechanics the division was
always intended to be based around long
story short the feelings I had playing
these game modes don't change the game
for me what we're all used to is still
there
but now we have to mix up the PvP style
of play solely relying on the chicken
dance just doesn't cut it anymore we
weren't able to play the game for long
enough to really break down what the new
meta style of play will be but at this
stage it does have a feel of being more
strategic and team orientated otherwise
I'll see you in the next video we will
dive a little deeper into some of the
skills and other game mechanics that
we're able to have a play with Cheers
[Music]
you